you can't mistake the growing gulf
between the rich and poor here
homeless camps piling up on affluent la
sidewalks
as tents move in there's a clear exodus
of residents moving
out homes now empty on hollywood's most
sought after streets removal companies
are working flat out
the black stuff goes after 17 years
living here
jeffer gassy is moving his family an
hour's drive away
kovid has been the catalyst but it's
laid bare
deep-rooted problems housing has always
been an issue here
and we're seeing that a lot i mean we're
seeing you know people who are moving
back in
with their parents the homeless
situation is
the visibility of it has gotten much
greater
it makes you feel a little bit uneasy
you know if somebody is a
block away and and living in a a totally
different lifestyle in a totally
different circumstance that
you know unfortunately has a high degree
of you know kind of desperation
homelessness is up 16 in la this year
and that was before covid since then
unemployment levels have hit nearly 20
percent
here and encampments in venice beach
have come to dominate
residential streets scott campbell moved
here
two months ago i've owned two homes
had the mortgage the insurance the the
responsibility
there's gonna be a lot of people out of
homes with this
everybody's you know stimulus this and
unemployment that and six feet away from
here
and rent's not being paid mortgages
aren't being paid so i would like to
show people how to do this
it's estimated another 36 000 households
in la
could end up homeless due to the
pandemic
this is one of la's wealthiest
neighborhoods to give you an idea
this is the gym where arnold
schwarzenegger trains
then right across the street you have a
google
corporate office and next to it there's
tent after tent of people living here
because they're homeless
and that is happening in street after
street
in this surrounding area it really is a
tale of two cities
stone's throw from the encampments the
immense wealth is clear
la has long been an expensive place to
live
but for many it's now not worth the
price what's going wrong
i i don't know that it's a gone wrong
thing
maybe get away from the attitude of oh
don't put that uh that housing project
in
my backyard it's got to go somewhere
these things won't go away by us just
putting the blinders on
and pretending they're not there we can
see that now
kovid has only inflated inequalities
that existed already
while those with money have the luxury
of leaving
the growing number who've lost
everything are in so many ways
simply left behind sally lockwood sky
news
venice beach los angeles